Nevada is among the top 10 states for
business women according to Startup NV
it's a non-profit which helps
entrepreneurs raise capital and attract
investors here's a look at a Las Vegas
success story as well as tips for female
entrepreneurs
we're a dual female founded company
Lindsey Ballenger and Marta spegman
moved to Nevada from California to get
their startup Safe Harbor off the ground
the company specializes in Secure
contactless cannabis transactions its
Locker product lets customers pay for
and pick up a dispensary order without
ever interacting with a person this
makes it easier for customers to get in
and out of the store and receive their
packages more safely and quickly the
lockers are currently in place at
Wallflower cannabis house off Blue
Diamond with plans to expand into other
businesses this pier credits their
success in part two startup NV what
we've done is really be able to build an
infrastructure that's much bigger than
just the two of us to be able to start
our company startup envies Maggie
sailing we're very welcoming to all
sorts of entrepreneurs and I think in
this state women are favored they
actually have the sense that they can
start and be successful here's why
startup NV says 31 of the funding
through the program supports
female-owned companies that's 13 times
the national average for similar
businesses companies founded solely by
women Nationwide last year garnered only
about two percent of the total Capital
invested in venture-backed startups
while women found adventures in our
state received six times that average
through startup Envy's fund envy and
Angel Envy programs we're really happy
to be working with Angel envy and
startup Nevada they're part of the
reason that we relocated to the state
and and one of the main resources that
helped us get to where we are in this
launch here's some advice for anyone
looking to start their own business I
would say stick to your dreams but learn
as much as you can and I would say also
that it helps to have mentors along the
way
fund NV is a for-profit precede Venture
Capital fund for startup Envy
accelerator companies and Angel Envy is
also operated by startup NV it trains
entrepreneurs for fundraising